[Musique]
ans
vous
la justice
une fois
[Musique]
oui
lundi
[Musique]
il ya d'abord des caractéristiques
sanitaires liés à la santé d'une manière
générale de cette population qui a un
taux de mortalité plus important le taux
de diabète notamment le taux de maladies
cardiovasculaires l'obésité oscille
voilà des facteurs qui font que cette
population est en moins bonne santé
générale
7 - bonne santé elle est liée si le
deuxième aspect à des conditions
sociales à des conditions de vie plus
difficile
on ajoutera aussi le fait que les
emplois ça c'est lié évidemment à la
situation sociale sont souvent des
emplois de première ligne en quelque
sorte d emploi de livreur des emplois
qui ne peuvent pas bénéficier du
télétravail et qui sont donc eux aussi
plus vulnérable par rapport à la
contamination de sciences puis enfin le
troisième facteur c'est l'assurance
maladie en effet la population africaine
américaine est moins bien assurée que le
reste de la population
en dépit de la loi obamacare qui a pu
assurer une vingtaine de millions
d'américains qui ne l'étaient pas avant
il reste encore une partie significative
de la population pauvre que ce soit la
population africaine américaine
la population hispanique mais aussi la
population amérindienne dans les
réserves de l'ouest des états unis en
particulier
qui ne disposent pas d'assurance maladie
[Musique]